un carro de masa m se mueve a la derecha
con una rapidez 2 v e impacta a un carro
más lento de masa m que se mueve a la
derecha con rapidez v cuando los carros
colisionan se enganchan entre sí existe
fricción entre la pista y los carros y
entre las partes móviles de los carros
cuál de las siguientes opciones
representa mejor el momento del carro
izquierdo como una función del tiempo
antes y después de la colisión antes de
ver las opciones los invito a que pausa
en el vídeo y traten de pensar en cómo
se vería una gráfica que describa el
momento del carro izquierdo como función
del tiempo y también aprovechen para
analizar cómo sería la gráfica del
momento del carro derecho vamos a
resolverlos juntos primero vamos a
comprender qué es lo que sucede aquí
estos dos carros tienen la misma masa el
carro izquierdo se mueve a la derecha
con una velocidad 2 v y el carro derecho
tiene la misma masa y se mueve a la
derecha pero a la mitad de la velocidad
que la del carro izquierdo como el
momento es masa por velocidad
el carro derecho tiene la mitad del
momento vamos a dibujar el día
el eje vertical es el momento y el eje
horizontal se refiere al tiempo el carro
izquierdo comienza con cierto momento
pero como hay fricción en el sistema
especialmente en las partes mecánicas de
los carros el momento va a ir
disminuyendo conforme pase el tiempo
recordemos que la fricción va en
dirección opuesta al movimiento por lo
que desacelera al carro izquierdo
entonces colisiona con el carro derecho
y parte del momento se transfiere del
carro izquierdo al carro derecho que es
más lento después de la colisión ambos
carros se mueven juntos a la misma
velocidad después ambos carros seguirán
disminuyendo la velocidad debido a la
fricción así que la gráfica del momento
del carro izquierdo se va a ver parecida
a esto pero además vamos a analizar lo
que le pasa al carro derecho recordemos
que el carro derecho tiene la misma masa
pero va a la mitad de la velocidad así
que comienza con la mitad del momento
también va a ir disminuyendo el momento
debido a la fricción
justo en el momento de la colisión el
carro derecho va a ganar momento y
después ambos carros irán juntos con el
mismo momento en esta gráfica se muestra
una línea para cada carro pero si
queremos ver la gráfica del sistema
combinado tenemos que sumar ambos
momentos y se verá como una línea que va
disminuyendo pero bueno en el enunciado
nos preguntan por la gráfica del carro
izquierdo que debe verse como esta línea
de acá ahora sí veamos las opciones que
tenemos para ver si hay alguna que
coincida con lo que analizamos aquí la
opción a tiene dos problemas el primero
es que parece que no existe fricción
porque el momento permanece constante lo
que indica que la velocidad a la derecha
permanece constante y después de la
colisión el momento se vuelve negativo
lo que implicaría que el carro con el
que impacta se mueve a la izquierda
recordemos que la convención que usamos
es que la dirección a la derecha es
positiva y que la dirección a la
izquierda es negativa descartamos esta
opción la opción c se parece a lo que
dibujamos pero nuevamente supone que no
existe fricción cuando el momento
permanece constante quiere
que la velocidad también permanece
constante en este momento ocurre la
colisión y después el momento vuelve a
ser constante así que también la
descartamos aunque si el enunciado
dijera que en el sistema no hay fricción
esta sería la opción correcta la opción
de se ve bien al principio pues describe
que hay fricción al inicio pero después
de la colisión el momento es cero lo que
indica que el carro izquierdo se detiene
esto no ocurre también descartamos esta
opción finalmente la opción b se parece
mucho a lo que dibujamos así que esta es
la opción correcta con esto terminamos y
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo